[Applause]
my god
you're about to be disappointed I'm very
glad to be here I'm I'm pretty stressed
out I have a ten-year-old son and
already at age ten we've had multiple
discussions on masturbation etiquette at
ten years old I was like please do not
knock on mom's door when she's
masturbating that's my time
get your own apple juice I'm working on
my own juice box thank you I can't
believe my son is ten years old I
remember when he was so tiny he fit on
the front steps of a nearby church
followed me I am a single single parent
and I don't date much when I do date I
try to have sex on the first date that's
not even a joke I just like to get the
word out when there's a crowd and TV
cameras spread this clip around please
it's not because I'm promiscuous it's
because I'm efficient I have to be my
babysitter cost 1650 an hour I can't
afford to go on dates that don't end in
penetration it's fiscally irresponsible
one time I was on a five-hour date and
at the end of the date the guy tried to
kiss me good night I was like oh no you
don't you either take off your pants and
join me in my garage or you give me 8250
in cash
he did both I'm assuming there's some
single parents here tonight a couple
yeah thanks for thanks for coming out
here I appreciate it the rest of you
guys
statistically many of you will be single
parents sorry I know you're in a great
relationship now but I have bad news for
you love dies and children live I hope
that joke saved a life tonight I really
do my son's father is Mexican and thank
you yes I was going to name my son Pablo
but then one of my white friends gives
wait a minute your son already has a
Hispanic last name maybe his first name
she'd be something more common if you
know what I mean yeah well I think I
know what she meant cuz I named my son
Mohammad it's the most common name in
the world
[Applause]
Mohammad Martinez that's my son he's
already been accepted into nine
universities and escorted off of 12
airplanes my son is much darker
complected than I am and he's very
obsessed with race right now an
ethnicity he goes mom am i white or am i
Mexican and I was like honey I don't
know how to answer that question let's
ask a cop
they're the experts we did and it turns
out my son is Mexican Hispanic male aged
9 to 11 backup I need backup I I would
like my son to be fluent in Spanish that
is muy importante
today don't be intimidated so I make him
take a lot of Spanish classes I also do
this thing where I don't let my son
speak any English
on Sundays it's a game that I invented
and I call it knowing glacé Domingo no
English on Sundays and how it works is
every Sunday I put my son in a different
life-threatening situation and I make
him talk his way out of it in Spanish
because I believe you can't be fluent in
a language until you can plead for your
life in that language anyway a couple of
Domingos ago we were on a walk and we
walked by a swimming pool and my son
doesn't know how to swim so don't get
ahead of me I pushed him in the pool
I said let's see what you got Mohammad
impress mom right and he immediately
defaulted to English he started yelling
help I know English Domingo as you can
imagine I was livid I said I would love
to help you dig a may in espanol my son
goes underwater to think
it's so quiet under there if you ever
have a chance give it a shot and then he
just shimmies out like a dolphin and he
goes now are you dar if you speaks me
honest you know it is a Spanish word
but it means to help to help
that's the infinitive that's
unacceptable guys when you're drowning
in English do you yell to help it
doesn't make sense so that's the how you
drown in Spanish I said mijo you
conjugate that verb properly or you're
gonna die guess what he did it he goes
are you then a puta oh my gosh what a
Mother's Day
[Applause]
you